the work you put in the decision that
you
made just to say yes cuz you know what
it's really easy when things don't go
well right and you're
hurt right and you're
angry and you're sad the easiest thing
to do is to pull back and
stop that's what the world wants you to
do but there's only a select few people
that are willing to freaking
fight and I am grateful for
you I'm grateful for what you've done
I'm grateful for who you are you deserve
better than that so I apologize to
you for you guys that are playing your
last
game get a season that will be
remembered
forever and I respect the hell out of
who you are for being in here today for
stepping on that field and go in and
give it everything forever you have my
respect